so halb Deutschland liegt schon wieder
krank im Bett vielen Dank Karneval
blödes Geburtstag ist aber eine sehr
gute Gelegenheit mal über unsere
klammerkrankenkasse zu sprechen die
gesetzliche leidet unter einem
historischen Defizit von 17 Milliarden
Euro betreu dem alten Slogan hohe Preise
keine Besserung
mein Gott was ist denn mit den
ratiopharm Zwillingen passiert
was tun gegen das kassenloch dazu kam
jetzt ein ja erfrischend widerlicher
Vorschlag von Bernd rufen dem Ökonom dem
die Arbeitgeber Vertrauen ja der
umgekehrte Robin Hood hier nimmt es
quasi von den Versicherten und fordert
das das gesetzlich Krankenversicherte
jährlich bis zu 2000 Euro
Selbstbeteiligung zahlen denn im Moment
haben wir natürlich einen Preis der Null
ist ich zahle nicht für meinen
Gesundheitsversorgung
man zahlt nichts welche Kasse bietet das
an ich wechsel sofort
Spaß ich bin der privatversichert mich
geht der ganze Scheiß nichts an und wenn
Sie sich jetzt fragen liebe Zuschauer
woher kenne ich das Schlechte
gottschalk-dubel hier richtig
Raffelhüschen ist bekannt geworden als
Hofnarr der Arbeitgeber Lobby Initiative
Neue Soziale Marktwirtschaft wo er uns
regelmäßig unterhalten hat mit
Schenkelklopfern zu Themen wie
Altersarmut es gibt keine Altersarmut in
Deutschland sie ist quasi irrelevant wie
schön wie schön was ist aber sehr wohl
gibt geistige Armut bei Bernd rufen das
geniale an seinem Vorschlag zur
Krankenkasse sie ahnen es sich ja schon
für Arbeitgeber würde sich da nichts
ändern dafür fordert er risiko-zuschläge
also wir ungesünder oder gefährlich
erlebt müsste mehr zahlen nach dem
Modell Raucher zum Beispiel ja klar oder
übergewichtige verstehen Sie das hier
wäre endlich wieder ein Status-Symbol
weil ich es mir leisten kann und klar
wenn ich darüber nachdenke ist es ja
auch irgendwo unfair das haben wir aber
kettenrauchende heidkäfig Taucher mit
Vorliebe für frittiertes Snickers
mitfinanziert werden von asketten wie
ihm hier ich esse gerne
und ich Spinat und viel andere Fisch
vegetarische Gerichte
und alle
lachsfischers Fritze fischt frische
Fisch vegetarische Gerichte
muss aber nicht immer lachsfisch sein ne
mir schmeckt auch meine leckere Scholle
oder Dorsch
die Ideen von Herrn Raffelhüschen mögen
eklig sein aber sie werden wenigstens
eine echte Reform die Ampel stopft die
Krankenkassen Löcher immer nur ganz
kurzfristig mit Steuer Milliarden und
ich sag mal so wenn Christian Lindner
weiter auf Schuldenbremse behaart und
ich wette dass du da kommt bald
spätestens nächstes Jahr eine richtige
Beitragserhöhung wir haben ja eins der
teuersten Gesundheitssysteme der Welt
und trotzdem warten Kassenpatienten oft
ewig auf einen Termin ne hat man mir
erzählt ja ja 43% warten laut einer
Studie regelmäßig über drei Wochen 17%
warten sogar mehr als drei Monate neue
Versuch bei einem Hautarzt in
Neu-Isenburg für mich gilt hier Ende
April mein Kollege als Privatpatient hat
bei ihm mehr Glück
das ist mir wahrscheinlich etwas zu
kurzfristig heute gleich
ja das sind Probleme das sind Probleme
da redet nie einer drüber was erst heute
hätten sie nicht gestern noch was frei
gehabt
solche Klassen beziehungsweise
kassenunterschiede sind seit 2019
eigentlich bei uns gar nicht mehr
erlaubt allerdings das wissen Sie immer
noch Realität was aus Sicht der Ärzte
sogar verständlich ist weil sich
kassenbehandlung für die oft schlicht
nicht rechnen ist ja so ungerecht bleibt
trotzdem warte mal da fällt mir ein
hatte dazu nicht ein berühmter
lachsfisch Freund mal was mal was
gewusst wir wissen dass wir eine brutale
2 Klasse Medizin haben und wir wissen
dass die Bürgerversicherung die Antwort
darauf wäre das wissen wir aber
sobald wir Minister also werden
vergessen wir es wieder
Bürgerversicherung zu Begriffen alle
Zahlen in eine Kasse was das Problem der
Unterfinanzierung der gesetzlichen auch
nur für ein paar Jahre lösen würde nach
hinten schieben würde liegt an der
Verdammten Überalterung aber fairer wird
es damit natürlich klar wird es fairer
wird auch unter der Ampel garantiert
nicht kommen hallo FDP so was bleibt dem
armen kassenpöbel unter diesen Umständen
kreative Ideen wie die hier
sie sind privat versichert und fragen
Sie schon lange wer die ganzen Elends
gestalten sind die bei ihrem Auto Helden
immer im Wartezimmer rumsitzen ja wer
sind die das sind sogenannte
Kassenpatienten die sitzen hier ewig und
drei Tage bis sie dran sind
ja aber das muss nicht sein seien sie
solidarisch und holen sich noch heute
Ihren
terminspendeausweis
Privatversicherte Leistungsträger
Spenden Facharzttermine die sie nicht
wahrnehmen weil das Wetter viel zu schön
ist um heute nicht Tennis zu spielen
oder
Golf wisst ihr was ich gehe lieber Golf
spielen und einer von euch los und kann
meinen Termin haben
warte mal vielleicht komm mit
und wer behandelt die ach die warten
sind die gewohnt
[Gelächter]
ja richtige neue Ideen sind gefragt ja
wenn die Bürgerversicherung nicht kommt
und ich würde sagen die kommt nicht
müssen wir das viele Geld im deutschen
Gesundheitssystem zumindest mal klüger
einsetzen digitalisieren endlich die
Mehrwertsteuer auf Medikamente senken
und Krankenkassenbeiträge nicht mehr nur
auf Arbeit sondern vielleicht auch mal
auf Kapitalerträge erheben welche Reform
macht Sinn reden wir darüber mit einem
der kränkten Menschen die ich persönlich
kenne mit Olaf Schubert Olaf schön dass
du da bist wir haben es gehört die Idee
höhere Beiträge für Leute die riskante
Sportarten betreiben die zu viel Essen
rauchen trinken kannst du dem was
abgewinnen
zweischneidiges Schnitt denn also ich
habe für mich also ich ernähre mich zum
Beispiel sehr bewusst ich lebe gesund
ich treibt wie viel Sport weil ich weiß
sie gesünder ich am Tag lebe desto mehr
kann ich nachts laufen und Rauchen ja
und drumruhen ähm
aber es ist natürlich trotzdem die Frage
wo fängt das Risiko an ja Fahrradfahren
das ist gesund so wenn ich jetzt
allerdings durch Berlin fahre und
nachher noch ein Döner für 230 esse dann
ist es eher ein potenzieller
Selbstmordversuch ja was ist mit Risiko
Berufen Dachdecker hochrissige Berufe
Lehrer ja also deshalb will ich weg von
diesen Eventualitäten hin zum verursache
Prinzip ja ich meine am gerechtesten ist
es doch wenn die Kranken einfach am
meisten bezahlen ja ich meine es heißt
ja auch Krankenkasse indem man den
Kranken so Kasse bittet ja
ich meine der Kranke verlässt ja auch
den solidarischen pack den ich meine
muss man den krank werden die meisten
sind ja gesund ja also es würde anders
gehen wenn man wollte
jetzt haben ja einzelne Krankenkassen
schon mal Experimente gemacht da konnte
man freiwillig so eine Art Trecker oder
sowas am Arm oder so haben und dann
wurde gemessen wie gesund man lebt wie
viel man sich bewegt die Blutwerte ist
fast zu viel Überwachungsstaat oder wäre
das eine Lösung naja also ein Trecker
und so das ist ja alles schnullifax also
wenn ich da wenn ich es richtig machen
will dann brauche ich eine elektronische
Fußfessel ja mit einer personifizierten
Drohne irgendwie wenn ich eben wirklich
valide Werte haben will aber das
kann ja so gar nicht leisten ja da
brauche ich dann eine Behörde dann
brauche ich ein richtiges Ministerium
für staatliche Fitness ja kurz Steffi
also
aber am besten ist natürlich wenn man
das gemeinsam irgendwie anpackt ich bin
ja groß geworden in einem Land da hat
man auf sich aufgepasst da hat man den
anderen motiviert warum sollte sich
heute auch gehen dass man sagt hier
Mensch Samantha
das ist aber eine schicke Hose gewesen
ja ähm
also
wir machen das bei uns im Haus auch so
dass wir uns da wirklich abholen und
mitreisen wir führen da also so haben
dass solche Listen und
wir hatten jetzt wirklich allerdings den
Fall dass ein Nachbar der hat sich
wirklich eine Woche oder über eine Woche
lang wirklich nicht ausreichend bewegt
und ich bin jetzt überhaupt nicht der
der da aber
was sollte ich machen ich musste dann
anrufen bei ihm und war dann Gott sei
Dank Entwarnung ne also der war schon
drei Tage tot
da kann man dann auch mal ein Auge
zudrücken oder beide aber ansonsten
ja hätte wirklich ein strafbänchen
bekommen müssen
mir möchte Werbung für zu salzige zu
süße fetthaltige Produkte verbieten und
er denkt dabei vor allem an unsere
Kinder die wohl immer übergewichtiger
werden hat er recht ja Werbung Werbung
Werbung also ich sag mal so in meiner
Küche hängt jetzt auch keine Werbung für
Bockwurst ja trotzdem fehlte sich meine
Frau jeden Morgen drei rein also
ich denke was bei Kindern wirklich hilft
ist irgendwie ganz konsequente
Abschreckung ja dass man sagt hier
Mensch wenn du deinen Möhren einen Topf
nicht ist dann kommt so ja das merken
Sie sich und wichtig ist natürlich aber
auch dass man als Elternteil dass man
glaube ich auch vor lebt dass man sich
Zeit nimmt ich mache das dann ganz
bewusst dass ich ab und zu sagen kommt
wir setzen uns jetzt mal richtig
gemütlich hin und dann essen war alle
zusammen keine Süßigkeiten
und dann sitzen wir da
Rauchen eine und
das ist jetzt natürlich nicht die Lösung
das ist klar das ist ein positiver
Ansatz aber das vergessen die auch
wieder weil die eben kein Bier vertragen
aber
in die Richtung sollte man halt gehen
dieser Mann hat fünf Kinder und wir als
Gesellschaft haben es nicht verhindert
Olaf Schubert meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
Olaf
Schubert so meine Damen und Herren und
dann
und dann da freue ich mich sehr gibt es
endlich mal wieder ein frisches und
verbrauchtes Aufregerthema Insekten im
Essen ja laut einer neuen EU-Verordnung
dürfen bei uns weitere Insekten als
Lebensmittel verkauft werden und ich
sehe das direkt auch hier bei uns im
Studio kämpfen viele jetzt mit ihrem
bürgerreflex ne ja ausgerechnet Gernot
Hassknecht der Mann mit der kürzesten
Zündschnur der Welt sieht pragmatisch
was Knecht Kochstudio heute pfiffige
Rezepte mit Insekten
hallo liebe lecker Mäuschen na auch Bock
auf ein schönes madengulasch an Schnaken
schauen nein
müsst ihr auch gar nicht Panik vor
Insekten im Essen ist gerade die
wichtigste Zutat im Populisten Kochbuch
die Botschaft wir normale haben die
Schnauze voll vom grünen Insekten Terror
herzlich willkommen bei denen die
anpacken bei die Zukunft glauben anstatt
sich auf die Straße zu kleben Insekten
zu fressen und auf den Weltuntergang zu
warten
und bevor sie jetzt sagen ja gute
Albaner so ist er halt der hat auf
seinem Hof eben über die Jahre zu viel
Gülle eingeatmet nein nein
insektenpanik ist der Hit in sämtlichen
Bierzelten wir essen wieder
Schweinsbraten statt Insekten oder Maden
Müsli und wenn ihr das wollt Liebe grüne
dann könnt ihr das Zeug selber fressen
walkness
Söder kein Mensch will euch
Schweinsbraten mitnehmen oder euren
ekelhaften Leberkäse was ist da denn
bitte drin streuende Katzen
wir nehmen es klaglos hin dass wir für
unser Trinkwasser wegen
Massentierhaltung immer tiefer buddeln
müssen aber Insekten sind eine große
Feind ja tatsächlich wegen dieser
Meldung ab heute dürfen grillen und
getreideschimmelkäfer zu und in
Lebensmitteln verarbeitet werden seit
Mitternacht gilt das entsprechende neue
EU-Gesetz
hochwertiges Eiweiß Mineralien sogar
Vitamine die Nahrung der Zukunft sagt
die UN und es ist ja nicht so das
Brüssel oder die Grünen mir die Tür
eintreten und mich zwingen Grillen zu
futtern oder Würmer
sollen wir jetzt essen
kommen wissen sie in der Gesellschaft ja
auf die Würmer kommt kann eigentlich
tiefer nicht mehr fallen okay Peter
Hahne und Hendrik im Bruder sind nicht
mehr die Jüngsten natürlich hat man in
dem Alter Angst vor Würmern
bevor sie euch essen
außerdem wir alle Schnecken Insekten
ständig glauben Sie nicht viele
Süßigkeiten sind mit Schellack überzogen
und das wird hergestellt aus Achtung den
Ausscheidungen der lackschildlaus auf
Tic Tac Kaugummi Kugeln oder den Dingen
hier
wunderbar ich
esse Schildlaus Experimente und dafür
stehe ich sogar manchmal nachts auf ja
lieber ich liebe extrem
ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile fast alle
versteckten Symbole hier bei uns im
neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf Youtube
boah also ich würde mich ranhalten